[Music]
from its opening stage sonic forces
displays a number of issues that are
emblematic of the journey ahead its
insistent tutorial messages interrupt
your initial sprint down a winding road
the cinematic transition sequences that
take you from one path to the next
renders you an observer not an active
participant and read as you're about to
settle to the Glee of your mad dash
forward the stage ends even sonic forces
most entertaining moments come with
caveats the game's story once again sees
sonic getting involved in the battle
against dr. Eggman who is joined by a
powerful entity known as infinite to
combat the threat a ragtag group of
freedom fighters consisting of Sonic a
younger version of himself most of the
supporting cast and a new character you
personally create simply named the
rookie come together while the story's
stakes provide an interesting power
shift where dr. Eggman has the advantage
thanks to infinite it falls short of
being interesting or impactful it's only
in Sonic forces is levity where it
manages to be somewhat entertaining
turning to puns or brief comedic
situations to elicit a snicker but all
too infrequently but what's that
you reek of fear glad to see I lecture
that's not beer I ran all the way over
here throughout your adventure you'll
switch back and forth between playing is
either modern sonic classic sonic or
your custom character the biggest
addition to the formula is your custom
character who sports special weapons
called wisp ons that grant unique
offensive and movement abilities all
three characters play distinctly from
one another and there are fleeting
thrills to be had and clung through
robots with a speed boost or using a
homing attack on a series of flying
creatures to quickly clear a path
towards the finish line
however the excitement of these
high-speed escapades are held back by
clunky platforming and unwieldy movement
during platforming and speed sequences
you frequently plummet down bottomless
pits due to how abruptly you care to
build up speed before a jump or how
erodes bumpers aren't made clear while
death is to be expected the level design
repeatedly miss communicates the
placement of oncoming hazards and the
timing required to avoid them admittedly
practice means you inevitably develop
the reflexes demanded of you over time
but even with experience the game's
inconsistencies mean you'll often end up
stuck on a ramp mid run or make a double
jump that simply doesn't work the way
you want the game also does a poor job
of teaching you the flow of its design
instead relying on multiple frustrating
and unfair deaths to educate you on the
intricacies of a stages pacing there's a
pervading sense of monotony across Sonic
Forces is-7 unremarkable worlds nearly
all the obstacles you encounter are
rehashes of concepts and mechanics from
previous games a set-piece sometimes
breaks up the pace
but these encounters usually boil down
to simplistic QuickTime events that make
you feel passive to the action happening
on screen rather than an active
participant
it also doesn't help that stages are
also incredibly short typically clocking
in at two and a half minutes with
cutscenes before and after each stage
you can't help but wish there was a
little more ground to cover before
reaching the finish line your custom
characters wisp ons add some variety to
the mechanics but even those are limited
as there are only a couple that offer
practical benefits for instance the
lightning wisp on allows you to zip
through a line of rings often leading
you to alternate routes in the stage out
of the seven West ponds available you're
likely to stick to using one or two as
there's rarely any incentive to
experiment once you've grown accustomed
to how a couple work
in terms of performance sonic forces run
smoothly at 60 frames per second on ps4
Xbox one and PC the switch version
however runs at 30 frames per second and
suffers from a downgrade in visuals
comparatively while docked or undocked
it'd be fair to write sonic forces off
as another weak entry in the series its
numerous shortcomings make for an uneven
often frustrating gameplay experience
however knowledge of its various flaws
can make for a smoother more gratifying
second run-through in replaying 4's
ranks it's possible to use your
accumulated knowledge of a stages
hazards and its most illogical pitfalls
to better your experiences but
speedrunning are not sonic forces Iselle
design stages and port handling are
still major obstacles that detract from
your time spent playing
[Music]
for years the Sonic series has come up
short in its 3d games
it wasn't until Sonic Colors and Sonic
Generations that the series was able to
grasp a semblance of quality that could
change the perception of the series for
the better
sonic forces ultimately fails to advance
the mechanics of previously successful
3d Sonic games or present them in their
best light a mediocre platformer at best
sonic forces simply deepens long-held
stereotypes against Sega's beloved blue
blur
[Music]
[Music]